we're back a little bit of a hiatus yeah
where were we well what were we doing
nothing in Potter absolutely nothing so
um we're getting hey that's for sure yes
um uh and we got the camera working
hopefully yeah I uh this is like we were
just sitting here fidgeting with this
damn thing for about 30 minutes yeah I
don't know the battery issue or a memory
card I feel like we're will exhaust it
before the V lugs even happen uh you
know it's so weird with everything
that's happened it's kind of like man
it's kinda nice just sit down watch some
cartoons hey you know just after all the
chaos and everything but people watches
years later on guy we're talking about
but I'm not gonna lie I kind of missed
it yeah you know I'll tell you the fine
thing it's a good show I'm like the
longer we went without seeing at the bar
I'm just like what a witch Steven
universe you know I think it's okay to
admit this when we were going through
all these Steven universes and it's a
good show and everything but we were
both kind of like okay let's just kind
of get through this and everything like
you know we weren't disliking it but we
were kind of getting a little tired of
it even though we know it's good and
they never let us down but it's like
well it's more than having to drink
about it cuz yeah I just feel there are
certain episodes where it's like that
was a good episode I just I don't know
what to say like I kind of just want to
enjoy the damn curtain and then once
this YouTube stuff happened you know
with the the strike and the monetization
and everything it's like suddenly it's
like okay just sit you know watching
some cartoons I'm really okay with this
I'm totally fine with this and I I kind
of missed it so it's nice to be back and
I know something must have happened
because okay we have a lot of people are
always like a one of the V was coming
back but then one day once again
everyone's like you have to do the I'm
just gonna guess that something gay
happened today
that's always what if he hits but but I
don't know I could be wrong
I'm trying to avoid spoilers every day
you're gay gay
I can't be both okay yes again so um
hairy gay gay and the day it happened
was a happy gay day so this is love
letters uh which is also a little gay
it's a but not happy gay gay no no that
this is more sad
yeah too tragic gay but it's a tragic
tragic gay I like then um so this is an
episode where we see Jamie the mailman
which according to our list we have not
seen before but they're acting like he's
a normal character so I don't know if
this was his introduction because again
that's just kind of how this show
anywhere episodes of the show I can't
remember was like did I see that I don't
I don't remember him but he's a mailman
uh for those who if you've are easy no
more nod who got back from the film
capital of the world Kansas and wanted
to become an actor Kansas and he runs
across guarded who just walked out of
the water that that's one of the
funniest intros of her just her coming
up like this mammoth monster um and he
instantly falls in love of course you
know she's already as they put already a
relationship so and she's not usually
very good words like that is in a
relationship no she literally is a
relationship so they have to tell him
that this can't really work and of
course garnet just writes no and that's
it oh no no no no right no and oh the
greatest the greatest rejection ever no
the end forever and after that yeah I
think when somebody asked me to do
something that's gonna be my reply no
the end forever and there's so many
posts like I wanna answer back with that
any bells
um so so they try to rewrite it uh in
their own poetic way like kind of what
he did and he misinterprets it garnet
comes out says I don't write that and
house one of the funniest deliveries
from her
accent drop no it totally dry that's why
I like suggest what
total American I don't rather uh one of
the funnies deliveries frying the bag
that she's got the swim mask over the
shade my god oh that's exactly the same
yeah um so she's heartbroken she goes is
actually very good with words and
explains that you weren't in love with
me you don't know anything about me
that's not love I really love that she
just dashes the love at first sight
doesn't exist because that's something
she would say and that's something that
a lot of times they really don't talk
about in cartoons how they don't talk
about a lot of romantic comedies and
stuff like that uh and she's just like
boom what's really talking about love
now that's not what this is and you're
so sucked up in drama that you've
convinced yourself and you convince
others and stuff that's not what this is
but hey that's a talent you should focus
on that that's all mostly here is love
yes um and uh and he's okay um I don't
know you but I saw you on this message
board and I think we were meant for each
other
um yeah this is another one of those
things where again I think one of the
reasons this show does so well and has
such an adult fan base as well I think
you could comic argument with the Milo
pony show too is that it's very much
talking about how to be social how to
connect and relationships and
friendships and stuff like that and not
everybody's very good at that so I like
it when a show can be very direct and
but very clever and very funny but also
very very careful about how it does it
and very soothing and very understanding
and I like when they do that but it's
still with garnet so there's that nice
directness where it's like hate just I'm
gonna tell it to you real and I'm gonna
try and be nice but it's not gonna be
I'm really gonna be direct
about this uh and I thought they did
that very well and I think for a lot of
people that do grow up kind of with
fairy tales and stuff like that you know
you do kind of need a show for cuz you
know this isn't something I think people
that watch like whatever snow white or
blue mermaid or something just really
watch it to see you
they won't watch at the same age by some
point there needs to be a show that
comes along and says hey look
that stuff's fine and we know you're
growing up and we know you're going to
figure it out but at some point you just
need to be told this isn't how it works
yeah I know night is nice for us yeah
well no no that honestly those everyone
that's like Cinderella and Little
Mermaid and Snow White's but unrealistic
unridden yeah think the movie with
witches and poison apples and mermaid
unrealistic no I know there is a Wiccan
religion okay you know it's almost like
they're called fairy tales or something
uh that really bothers me when they
think people are so stupid that they're
gonna grow up with this mindset I'm sure
somewhere some people are but I get the
feel of it even with our fairy tale any
event at such people right how do I put
it it's I get the fan thing would be
like that even without these fairy tales
the fairy tales are not the cause of
them no but they always cite fairy tales
as a you know there's always that one
for every for all the normal Disney fans
there's always that one obsessive Disney
fan who's just like no is a wish your
heart makes and a diamond that drops in
the Cabbage Patch it was love it for
side none their whole life is like a
freaking fairy tale and after a while
you're just like shut off huh well and
let's say this too you know the idea of
love at first sight I mean it's
attraction at first sight is a thing
totally and maybe you can fall in love
after that um but the idea of no I see
this person and I know you it's like
everything she said about love takes
work love takes time you had to find out
about the person you can't know you know
it's near the edge too cynical now if
you find someone and you're attracted to
them and you don't let me go talk to a
beautiful person or whatever and you get
along and you do fall in love great I've
known several relationships that would
have not at least the sex was good and
now you got a nice eye candy to think
about later at night when do you do
things so it's not as talking about
Santa's got weird
so I think it's one of those things
where even though I think a lot of
people like to blame Disney for their
own idiocy on things like that but no
yeah hell no Oh take some personal
responsibility yeah um but there is
something where it's just I think people
can see it might be it's not okay no
it's not Disney is romantic comedies
that's what I don't like I don't like
when they try to show you this is how it
works these are how relationships work
and you know our romances and all these
other things when there's a real
romantic feel couples getting together
getting married that could be
interesting and then if you love stuff
is right now you can go I think women
know it the smart women know that
they're stupid in the same way that I'm
like you know Arnold Schwarzenegger
films give us unrealistic expectations
about what a man can accomplish like
come on
no but here's the thing oh it a real
real romance real and I can't election
ships and stuff like that can be
interesting can be funny can be dramatic
but we don't get those and that annoys
me but the chart says yeah no I know
here's a funny thing actually I'll even
make a bigger I think you were 100%
right most women know this I need some
obviously you don't but most know it and
it's my wife loves dumb romantic
comedies watches them all the time as -
but she's literally watching it
Wow this is Tara no not now here's the
problem and I'm not necessarily maybe it
isn't the fault of the movies I do think
we need more realistic interesting good
romantic romance films but with men I
don't think they always catch on that
this is not how you start a relationship
this is not how you begin talking to a
person these are still fairytales the
movies that you see you know with Will
Smith or all these people you know that
just so smooth and cool and stuff but
those are still fairy tales and if
someone like Jim Lee says get away from
you but you should get away from them
you know it's not know it coming get me
again or whatever or you know Reese
Ingalls there's this very social you
know interesting way of doing this kind
of stuff and interacting that you can't
find out unless you just go do it so you
know I think this is very much a female
that drama I don't wanna say
to send the same men that would do that
are like the women who believe in the
fairy tale happy ending nobody I'd okay
your talk about the internet and how
many guys there are like this and stuff
you know there's probably more guys that
think this is how it works then there
are women that think this is how well
you guys always think they're being
smooth but in reality they're throwing
out one-liners like Anakin Skywalker yes
sack of a clone yes and I wasn't
particularly at conventions I'm like you
know you think you're this but you're
really sitting there going I like you
you're smooth like water I'm like sand
but but but let's be honest we've gone
too you know we've hung out bars and
stuff when we seen you know men try to
hit on women even like good-looking
smooth you know suit wearing men and
stuff like that and they just try these
lines in these pick-up lines and it's
like you can't be serious yeah but we've
seen it also works hey well that's
Nana's catcher which means maybe that
idiot found another idiot and maybe
those idiots were meant for each other
or maybe that's just gonna be one big
disaster and they're both gonna regret
it I don't know and here's the thing if
you're just looking for fun fair enough
you do the dance you do the one-liners
and stuff and see you go but I've seen
people who try this and like the other
person with man woman whatever is
clearly not interested and they just
keep going and I really get the feeling
that's like the mentality that we get
from these romance it's like no no just
keep pursuing keep going and I just get
a feeling it's like they're not seeing
that's a fairy tale too and fairy tales
are fine and they're great escape and
sometimes you can learn lessons but it's
not reality you have to just go out
there try and observe and see what works
and see what doesn't and find out what
you're looking for and hopefully find a
person's looking with the same thing
don't be that douchebag yeah like um oh
no there's women that try this too there
there are some very you know hyper
fangirl it's not a complete work of
fiction oh no no no no there's
definitely women out there you know that
could do this um but you know and it
gets awkward all this actually found out
there isn't it there's a report that
says there's any more female stalkers
that there are male stalkers
which I found fascinating unlikely I
believe that see that was like us with
the internet culture and everything you
know that's like really like you would
really think about wait there's why
because think about internet culture if
you're really good at stalking you're
not going to advertise your stalking men
are just too loud you piss men off all
of a sudden is it gonna hell I'm gonna
comment I'm not getting it out I'm a
media I'm a mega terrible stalk I get a
really good stalking you shouldn't see
the person that I'm gonna happen yeah
like that's just
those are like 10 year old like you're
30 oh man children like you know and
their parents basically I felt in the
best qilin in heaven or five-year-olds
but yeah just learn how to swear yeah
but true real stalking yeah that's a
talent so um so yeah back to Steven
universe uh but but I'm a rape no but
that is what it was just our got us down
this no but that is kind of what's going
on in this episode and I I like for that
I like it is addressing the stuff that
you know he was brilliant he was a
really creepy stone no no but he was
definitely very emotional an idiot we we
have all either seen or been the people
that wear their hearts on their sleeves
and we'll just give it to someone not
having any idea who you're giving it to
look least or one can see the exact
moment when his heart breaks right there
so it's it's one of those things where
it's I don't know it's especially with
the internet and is this is why I like
the movie frozen a lot too I think it
does address both how sort of shut off
from reality and kind of closed off and
anti-social you can be or how just
totally out there telling everybody
everything giving your heart to anyone
how dangerous that can be either and I
think this is very much the giving your
heart to anyone scenario um that can be
like no you gotta be careful with this
you know and to be cautious I mean
garnet was nice and you know did try to
tell them how things are but you know
it's like you can get a lot of messy
stuff you know it is your metaphorical
surgeon god that was so great that was
so fun
um so uh yeah how about you I have never
been in love so I don't know yeah it's
you picked a good beard though I meet
the wedding and everything I mean that I
don't know it all it was really legit I
well we got to keep up appearances we
have to appear normal
so the bud well done well halftime be
normal and reality I married a lamp it's
normal in some countries well it's nice
to see that the spark is still there
well too bright not really I'm kind of
looking at this lamp over here oh hey
baby yes true how's it going it'll turn
out my lights a funky the light of my
life I can't do this mmm she's got a
good ball I mean a very happy loving
relationship not with a lamp let's let's
clarify that everything I have to say
that you got spelling things out online
derail booth yeah sorry um bottom line
it's good to be back lamps are hot I
warm hmm they're really hot it's gonna
catch fire that's true
smoke so what's that lamp doing tonight
mm-hmm
does that lamp ever friend you know I
know what lamps doing tonight me Oh